[inaudible].
So first of all, thank you all for coming
today and thanks for having me again.
Uh, APP. Google is always
very nice to be here. Um,
so I've written a few books now and
this latest one, the Nordic baking book,
you'd actually marks the end,
uh,
to a six year research process that
produced the Nordic cookbook after three
years and now finish this
with this publication.
And it's,
um,
the whole purpose of these books were to
be documentary and to tell people about
Nordic food culture in a true way because
I think that Nordic food culture is
one of the most misunderstood food
cultures on the planet. I mean, uh,
largely because of people like
myself actually, because if you, um,
if you search on the Internet for a
Nordic food culture in order to cooking
things like that,
uh,
the first thing you get up is like a
thousand articles about Favi. Again,
the noma and a handful of other
very ambitious contemporary
restaurants and none
of them really are very indicative of
how people actually in the Nordics.
Um,
and then aside of that,
you also get the whole bunch of recipes
for a gravlax for hiring and for
meatballs and cinnamon buns.
And those are Nordic dishes.
But that's not really what people
need them and everyday basis either.
And then the last thing,
you get this like a lot of people
photographing their meatball Mila at Ikea.
So I felt that,
uh,
there was a real need for these books and
it's been an enormous privilege to get
to spend this long, uh, supported
by publisher researching,
researching my own food culture,
the food culture that I thought I knew a
lot about and that it turned out that I
knew a lot less than I
thought about. Um, and, uh,
it's, it is a bit strange now to
see this, both books, outs, um,
the project being done.
But it's also amazing to see people
interact with both of the books,
tagging me in photos on
social media of bands.
They've made people coming
to these lectures and, uh,
really learning about food culture that
I think they knew very little about
before.
And one thing that I learned,
especially during the second half of this
project is how great the diversity and
the depth of Nordic Bacon culture.
And I come to believe very firmly that
Nordic baking culture is actually the
greatest bacon culture on the planet
today in terms of diversity and depth.
And that might sound a little bit
less than obvious for most people. Uh,
and,
uh,
my plan now is that I'm going to spend
the next 30 minutes or so talking about
sort of making my case for Nordic
Bacon Culture and then, uh,
I'll open up for some questions towards,
towards the end.
Do we have a problem? Sorry, Justin. No,
Dustin. Um, so the,
the best place to start
when we talk about culture,
it's the people because without people,
we can't have any culture
baking or otherwise.
And the Nordic region,
it's inhabited by about 26 million people
and they're spread out the a surface
area just under 3.5
million square kilometers.
And that column by any stretch be called,
particularly then as they populated,
I mean, uh, we can compare
this to, for example,
the whole rest of Europe
without the Nordics,
which would then have about 90
people per square kilometer.
It's even more interesting if you start
comparing to specific countries. Uh,
let's say France for example, France
has 116 people per square kilometer.
Germany,
the most populous country in Europe
has 237 people per square kilometer.
And as a little example,
to compare it to two,
if you were to take all of the Germans
and you have to spread them out in an
even layer across their whole country,
you would end up having a German
every 75 knee jerk in every direction,
one even layer. If you were to
do the same in the Nordic region,
there will be 375 meters
between each person.
And that's a huge difference.
So we have this vast
geographical area with a very,
very scarce population. Um, I mean
if we were to go back in time,
let's say a few hundred years to,
uh,
to an era when a lot of what we consider
our cultural identity of today was
actually founded,
what would this scarcity
of your population actually
have meant for the way that
knowledge was transmitted
between people and anyone?
Give me some examples perhaps. What
do you think, what would this mean?
Think before like social
media, television, cell
phones, all of this stuff.
Anyone else?
A lot of word of mouth. I mean the,
the, the, I think that the, um,
the most important sort of
general observation about
the difference between now
and then we'll be that, uh, information,
knowledge everywhere would have been
transmitted at a much lower pace back then
than it is now. And as
you say, word of mouth,
you essentially had to talk face to face,
to a person to acquire the information
that they might have a or you had to
write the letter. And
I think that, I mean,
we can all agree that writing a physical
letter, although it's a beautiful thing,
a,
is not a particularly efficient way of
lots of information quickly or I mean the
third option, if she wanted to
learn from a trusted source,
you could also read a book.
And back then,
I mean 300 years ago there
were like three books.
One was the Bible and then there were
two more that didn't deal with baking
Heider. So, uh, I mean none of these
things would have actually, uh, um,
really done much for the cultural baking.
So if we were to agree,
then that information flowed
slower everywhere because
of the lack of technology.
I think we can also imagine that in an
area as scarcely populated as the Nordic
region,
this effect would have been further
exaggerate them simply because series just
much more distance between each person
that you can interact with face to face.
And this is very important for my recently
and it's something that I will come
back to a little bit later. Um, and now
I'm going to make an example as well,
sort of to illustrate this.
And so I have a,
my good friend Joe on here
tonight is it's there in the back.
He happened to be San Francisco today,
so he just came here to
have a little look as well.
And let's say that Yo one tomorrow would
invent a new cake recipe and he's not
just any cake recipe.
It's actually the most delicious cake
recipe ever invented by humankind.
It's completely revolutionary.
Um,
and he would bake this cake recipe.
Maybe he would share it with his family
and he would do what most people do
today when they do something they're
proud of some, some kind of achievement,
he would share it on social media.
And because of this key,
and it's extreme deliciousness,
I mean, everyone who sees it on social
media, they're a bit excited because,
I mean, he's claiming that he's
made the world's best cake, right?
And perhaps a few of them will ask for
the recipe and they will do the same
thing.
They were also bake it and little by
little sort of information generation by
information generation.
Um,
this cake recipe spreads out into the
world and then all of a sudden maybe, uh,
you know, it hit someone with a
bit of, you know, a bit more reach,
perhaps a couple of hundred
thousand followers and it
gets even further out into
the world of information.
And all of a sudden it's featured
in Martha Stewart living, I mean,
no one's cake recipe.
And then it takes one more week and
it's my birthday back home in Sweden and
Tova my wife, who has also
done a lot of the, uh,
recipe development for these two books.
She's made birthday cake,
but it's not my normal birthday cake,
which is the green Marzipan layer cake,
which is, you know, the princess cake, the
most delicious birth, the birthday cake,
the race, I think. No, no, it's another
one. It's a new one, but it's not Yo,
when's cake either.
It's the Vegan raw food version of your
landscape that Toby has gotten from her
goop newsletter.
And,
and that's sort of how information
flows today when it comes to, um,
food much, much. And not
only does it spread quicker,
lead more quickly over a large area,
it also mutates quicker
into new versions of itself.
And this is a huge difference.
I mean, this isn't,
hasn't been going on for very long.
And if we were to compare this with how
things were back couple of hundred years
ago, I mean, you're one could
still have invented the cake.
It will there be an equally
delicious as most today. Uh,
he would have made it for his family
and then like, that would have been it,
right?
And then perhaps a,
when your hands kids were to
leave the house, you know,
after 20 years of eating his cake,
uh,
perhaps they got married into the
neighboring farm 800 meters away. Um,
another four people with I learned
about the cake. So in, in, you know,
in the span of 20 years, it
would have a spread, you know,
spread over a diameter of two kilometers
and eight people would have known about
the case. The most delicious cake
invented by human guide. Uh, and I mean,
this is a bit of an over exaggerating,
but I think,
I think that if you get the
point, um, and to put this simply,
a scarce population spread out over a
vast area used to me and to some extent
still means today that knowledge
travels slower, um, this and it's turn,
it will always mean that you get the
more varied expression of all commonly
practiced culture.
This is simply because people are less
influenced by charter because they,
you know,
do less of the same stuff.
And this is one reason to why the
Nordic region has a more diverse baking
culture than almost any
other region in the world.
And other reason for this diversity,
um,
that is also somewhat related to the
Scarsdale population and we'd really
influences the, uh, making culture. It's
the bakeries and their role in society.
And in the Nordics baking culture,
it's not carried primarily
by commercial bakeries,
but rather by people in their homes.
And this is not just something that used
to be accurate in the past. It's salty.
It's something that still
applies today. And, and this is,
I mean,
it has to do with geography because
what does bakeries need to sustain
themselves? Customers. Exactly.
I mean, they're going to
need to have people there.
And if you have a 375 meters through,
you know,
every person that's not many.
Um,
and I mean there are definitely
bakeries in the Nordics.
There's always been
bakeries in the Nordics,
but there are concentrated in
quite a small geographical area.
At least they used to be historically.
Um,
I mean you would have found most
of these bakeries that were, uh,
sort of common enough to produce
red as a daily staple in cities.
And most of the cities in the Nordics
are in the southern third of Sweden,
a bit on the, uh, sort of southwest
coast of Finland. All of them,
mark and then an area or you know,
around Oslow and a bit up
on the west coast of Norway.
That's where you would have found these
cities that were big enough to sustain.
Baker is in the past.
And I actually did a little test
when I did another talk that was on a
completely different subjects. Uh, yes.
Some weeks ago I had 100 people in the
room and I ask them all what they thought
was the greatest bacon culture on the
planet. None of them's the Nordic.
What do you guys think? They said? Yeah,
they said the France or
99 of them said France.
And then there was this one
guy who was an Austrian.
And I mean,
I started thinking about this and,
and I think that I would've said Francis,
well,
before starting with this project
and I started thinking more about,
I mean, what, why did, why
does everyone think this?
Like what's the substance behind,
uh,
this immediate assumption from
almost every person you meet?
The French Bacon culture is the greatest,
greatest on the planet.
I think that this simply a
case and a great example,
or very,
very clever and successfully executed
branding exercise by the French.
You know, you visit France, uh,
there is, uh, but gets you buy them,
they're already clarity by them. And then
you'll have a great time in France. Um,
and I mean, if we start to look at
what French baking culture actually is,
it's the polar opposite to
with Nordic Pagan culture.
Looks like I would on something
strange. Oh, good. Um,
as opposed to ours,
uh,
the French baking culture is almost
entirely driven by professional bakeries.
People in France, they don't
bake that much at home. And
I mean, why would they? Um,
there's a bakery in every tiny little
village in France and France is very
evenly and quite densely populated
as we said before. So I mean,
there's absolutely no incentive
to bake your own bread, uh, on a,
on a regular basis so that
it becomes a daily staple.
And if we take this a step further and
think about what this actually means for
the culture of eating and baking bread,
um,
I imagine that many in this room,
perhaps almost all of you have been
to France and you've bought and eaten
something from a French bakery.
Perhaps you were there on vacation. I
mean, perhaps you live there for awhile.
I don't know.
Uh,
but I think that most of us can agree
that French bakeries are lovely places.
I mean,
the gets the butter across som to
partial Kula Africa turnovers flow path.
I mean,
all of these things are examples of great,
great pastries and bakes. And I
too love a French bakery. I mean,
I used to live there.
Uh,
I've been to a lot of them and
not just in Paris where I live,
but all over the country. And when I
started thinking about these things,
one thing that I realized that
there are pretty much all the same.
They share almost exactly
the same repertoire of baked
goods regardless of where
in France they are. And I mean, sure,
the butter roll into a
croissant in Brittany might
be a little bit saltier than
the one I was at.
A Nice,
perhaps the apricots are fresh in the
south and their cabin in the north.
And there are definitely some
regional variations and some, uh, uh,
regional specialties that are added on
to this standard repertoire across the
country. But all in all,
they are remarkably similar.
And as I said before in France, people
rarely bake at home. And if they do,
they bake, uh, the search,
you know, might go to a,
the bakery by a role of a puff
pastry and go home and make telethon.
That's sort of the extent of it.
And I mean,
as you can understand,
this is a not exactly a great
growing ground for a in cultural,
cultural individuality and diversity.
And I mean,
this is because businesses,
bakeries are businesses and the businesses
they have to function financially.
And I mean this happens when you find
that sweet spot between what people want
to buy and what's actually possible to
produce in a, an efficient enough manner.
So there is always going to be,
for all cultures,
cultures dominated by
businesses, certain, uh,
circumstances and rules around them that
will shape and quite the large degree
streamline these places produce.
And I think that very often we'd food,
we tend to forget this because we were so,
I mean,
we take that for granted and we don't
really see food as part of normal business
even though it is obviously.
And I think you can make, um,
a bit of a, an interesting
comparison with, for example,
other types of manufacturing.
Let's say that you compare
bakeries and car companies.
So almost all car companies except
for some cosmetic differences make
essentially the same product,
right?
Rectangular box wheel in each corner.
It goes either like that or
like that. Then you know, it,
they kind of do the same thing.
Um,
and the same rules apply there because
they're a business, you know, uh,
and they've collected,
we figure out the best way of producing
something that's as close as possible to
where people want to buy. And it's
exactly the same for the bakeries.
And also most bakeries,
they're run by bakers and
most bakers who run Baker's,
they've also gone to school somewhere
where they learned how to debate.
Incidentally,
they learn how to bake exactly the same
way as pretty much all of the others who
also went to school and started bakeries.
And because their business model
works and has worked for a long time,
most likely what they're going to teach
the next generation of bakers is some
iteration of what they're already doing.
And none of this really
promotes diversity and culture.
Um,
so in a bacon culture driven by bakeries,
you will inevitably only have a fraction
of the diversity found in a culture
that's driven by people
baking in the home.
And this is another reason
why there is no more diverse,
diverse baking culture in the
world than in the Nordics.
And I actually think that a comparison
between the u s and Sweden here and we
get it straight, it's the differences in
how much people actually bake at home.
Because something that I've understood
here in the US now when we've done all of
the recipe testing with independent
recipe testers in America to see that the
recipe is actually function.
And also something that I've come to a
talk a little about you bring this tour
when we were meeting people and
talking about the book is that um,
it's hard to buy fresh yeast here.
I mean,
essentially it seems to me that if you
want to buy fresh yeast in America,
you have to sort of sneak up in the alley
behind some bakery and like go in the
back door and buy some of their
yeast stash, you know, uh,
which is very different from
how it will be in, for example,
Sweden where you can buy fresh
yeast and every grocery store,
every petrol station, every
seven, 11, many new stands,
we'll have fresh cheese that is not just
because they have a pretty yellow color,
the cubes and you know,
people have them for fun.
It's because people buy them and people
buy them because they want to bake with
them. Um, and I think that this
illustrates how big a part of,
um, people sort of home cooking,
baking makes out in the Nordic region.
And then you'll have
geography and climate.
Another very important influence on
what people eat. And as I said before,
the Nordics,
it's a vast region.
I mean from the southern most bits of
Denmark all the way up to the northern
parts of Spitsbergen islands,
north of Norway,
from Finland in the east to green.
Then all the way in the West is a huge
region and you can fit all of the rest of
Europe a whole bunch of times in there.
I think you can fit the whole universe
in there as well. Easily and sure.
I mean a lot of this is ocean,
but that doesn't really matter because
when it comes to cultural diversity, uh,
dependent on the geography,
it's not, you know,
the important thing is not
that it's evenly populated.
Important thing is the distance between
the extremes where people actually live
and in terms of climate
naturally in such a vast area,
you will also have a lot of
variation and this and it's turn.
It will mean that people are what people
have been able to grow in the past and
thereby bake wood and integrate
into our culture. It's very,
the lot depending on where they live.
And you can think of wheat, for example,
we this a grain that needs a fairly
particular circumstances to grow.
Well, we need a long enough
in a warm enough summer,
it needs quite a lot of water and it
needs very fertile ground to grow well.
And these circumstances you won't
find everywhere in the Nordic region.
You'll actually find them pretty much in
that same region where all of those CPS
were located. Funnily, you know, um,
so in the southern third of Sweden,
a little bit on the, uh, uh,
finished west coast a little bit,
didn't South Norway and all over Denmark.
That's where we was traditionally grown.
And it's also where most of the wheat
based recipes in traditional Nordic baking
happens to come from. And funnily
enough, what used to be, uh, you know,
practical limitations on, in
this essence, this in the past,
it tends to inform our
choices today a lot.
And then you can go on and you
can look at, for example, Denmark.
So Denmark has the most fertile
farmland in the Nordics.
It's a great agricultural production area.
And they grow a lot of weeds.
And wheat has always been a, an important
trade commodity, very expensive.
So what they used to do historically is
that they grew the weeds on their best
land and then they sold it off to
continental Europe, almost all of it.
And on all of the poorer pieces of land,
instead of wheat,
they grew ry because ry,
it ripens very dependently
every summer in Denmark.
And the therefore have a really
great ride bread culture.
And because southern
Sweden is close to Denmark,
you'll also find a bit of Rye bread there.
And you'll find in both Denmark and
South Sweden breads that you historically
wouldn't have found anywhere else,
which were brands that had both rye and
wheat in them because unique to this
area.
And then you can look at Finland.
Finland has almost all rye,
almost no other grains are used
in traditional finish baking.
And this is because most of the
countries located too far north.
So it's too cool in the summer for a,
the wheat to grow there. And then in the,
in the sort of southern part, the
warmest part of Finland, um, it's, it's,
it has inland climate
towards the Russian border.
So even if it would have been warm
enough for the week to grow there in the
summer would have been long enough. It's
too dry so it doesn't work. But Rye,
it can take a lot less water during
the summer so they have, uh, you know,
it and it informs all of
their bacon culture where I
grew up further north up in
Sweden,
uh,
you can't grow wheat because it's too
cool and the summer you can't grow rye
either for the same reason. So people use
to grow oats and barley and oats have,
it has no gluten at all in it.
And Barley,
we'll have a little bit of gluten and
gluten. You need to make fluffy breads.
So the further north you
come in Scandinavia, the
flatter the bread's will be.
You know,
until you hit the point,
sort of halfway up through Sweden and
Norway where I used to grow up, um,
where the traditional Bates
would be only flatbreads,
either soft or dry.
And I mean, I'm going to compare this
to France again. Yes. Because it's a,
it's a very easy comparison to make.
So what Greens do we find in France?
It's like wheat everywhere.
They grow almost exclusively
weeds, I mean, and why would
they grow anything else?
Uh, pretty much all of the country except
for like the warmers and DIYers bits
towards the southeast as a great growing
climate for weeds and wheat is in
Europe and has traditionally been
the most well paid for grain crop.
But then you look at, you know,
the repertoire or recipes,
almost all of the recipes for both the
breads and savory pastries in France.
They're based on one single grain, which
is sweet. If you look all of the Nordics,
I mean we've had four different
grains who've all been, you know,
equally important to
specific parts of the region.
Meaning that we have four times as
much base material to work with,
meaning more diversity. We can do
the questions afterwards. Sorry.
So these sort of climate and it's,
it's limiting factors has historically
created a lot of diversity. Uh,
and as, as I said before, the
Nordic region is also vast,
but it's a vast region that's located
almost all of it in the marginal climates
and it's marginal in a sense that for
people to successfully live there,
you know,
you have to plan ahead a little bit.
You can't just expect to harvest plant
based foods all throughout the year,
which we,
which we shouldn't be the case and
quite a large part of the military and
Mediterranean area. Um, you know,
a big part of Asia for example,
and a lot of warmer climates in the world,
you wouldn't really have any
incentive to, um, store foods,
at least not for a longer period of time.
And the interesting thing with
all of these marginal climates,
it doesn't really matter
where you are in the world.
They have two product groups in common
that have been like a huge historical
importance.
Um,
and essentially things that made
people live through the harsh winters.
And those two product groups.
There are grains and dairy
and both grains and dairy.
There are not only high in energy,
but they're also very easily produced
in large quantities during fairly cool
summers.
And on top of that,
both grains and dairy there are
easily prepared for storage.
I mean with there you can think like
culture, their products, butter, cheese,
all things that keep really well and all
things that are very dense in energy so
they don't talk, they don't take up a lot
of storage space when you keep them. Uh,
for the cereals.
I mean all seeds of perennial
grasses make great storage crop.
They dry well,
um,
the store well and they can be turned
into a lot of different things.
And it doesn't matter. I mean, if
you're a in the Peruvian Andes,
if you're in a monastery,
in Bhutan, in the Himalayas,
or if you're like in a suburb
of us too soon where I grew up,
it doesn't matter if it's a corn or a
red rice or wheat or if it's milk from a
lama or York or cow.
The same sort of basic principles
apply all of these marginal climates.
And I think that baking, which I thought
was going to be very easy to define,
the baking is turns out that
is not easy to define at all.
And I think that baking is simply like
a catch all phrase for all of the ways
that humankind can,
uh,
turn grains sometimes in the
combination with dairy into a food.
How we can turn,
can turn a these two basic product
groups into something that's more easily
digestible, more tasty and
more varied than, you know,
the products are on their own.
And I think that the fact that we've
created so much variation with such a
limited number of base products as we
have in baking compared to savory food,
I mean, just imagine how
almost all baking recipes,
they contain like the same five
things in different variations.
And if you look at the savory cooking,
you have thousands of different
based products that, you know,
becomes various combinations.
And I think that there's great diversity
in number of recipes and expressions in
baking. It really, uh, uh,
says a lot about how important and how
big a part of our daily caloric intake
that used to come from grains and
dairy. You know, we were really,
really motivated to create a
lot of diversity in recipes.
So today,
uh,
we often tell ourselves that we decide
what we eat all the time that no one else
dictates what products we buy
and what we make from them.
And from my perspective, this is
obviously completely wrong because I mean,
we are animals and we do exactly
what our species is always done. We,
we procure whatever products that
make sense to us there and then,
and we prepared them in whatever way
that makes sense to us there. And then,
and then we eat them ourselves or with
our flock. I mean, that's what we do.
And the thing though that
fascinates me so much with this,
especially when it comes to baking,
it's the amount of cultural knowledge
that transmitted between generations
because eating correctly,
grown, preserved, stored,
and subsequently prepared foods
made from grains and dairy,
it used to be incredibly
important for ancestors. Uh,
for them it was a simply about survival,
which is the single strongest motivating
force of the human being today for
almost all of us eating breads and cakes
and buns and cookies or whatever else
we've baked, it's mostly
about pleasure. Right? Um,
and why do we find it's so pleasurable?
The EEC explanation here is that these
items are dentists in energy and that we
are predisposed to like things that
are dentists in energy and that might
explain why we find a piece of cookie,
very tasty,
but it doesn't explain why we're so
motivated to pass on this cultural
information between generation and
why it's so pleasurable to bake.
And I think that's simply a are you know,
humankind's sort of,
um,
function put in flight in
place by humankind in our
subconscious minds to make
sure that we don't lose this information.
Yes.
Because there's a new generation coming.
Um,
I mean almost everyone I know take more
pleasure and they feel more satisfied
when they've baked something than
when they've cooked something savory.
I mean personally I'm more happy,
but you know,
when I bake a sponge cake than one day,
then when I'm making an oven omelettes.
Um, and I think this is just a really
good a indicator, you know, on,
uh, how our minds function. And
this sort of boils down to my final
big reason as to why the Nordic Bacon
culture truly is the
greatest around there. Uh,
preparing all of these grains
and dairy products. Well,
it's used to be more important where I
come from than in almost any other part
of the world.
And I think this is also the reason why
most people in the Nordics still bake
more in their homes, then people
doing other parts of the world.
We just take more pleasure in it because
it used to be more important for us in
the past. And as we'd all culture, I mean,
if culture is regularly practiced,
you know, on an everyday basis,
if culture is allowed to, um, uh,
change gradually because of use,
it will always be more diverse and deeply
rooted than if it's carried out by the
Sfu people or you know, uh,
kept intact in a bubble.
And I think this is like the final
reason from my side too. Why, uh,
the Nordic Bacon culture is just the
most diverse making culture on the planet
today.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
and now we can do questions.
Do we have in Miker? Yeah.
Cool. And it can be questions about this,
uh, about the project with these books.
They can be questions about Favi and
my restaurant can be questions about
anything you want really.
So Rachel Hanson,
you mentioned that sort of during the
process for researching this entire
project that, uh, you
thought at the beginning,
you knew a lot about serving more
include culture in order to compete and
culture, but you found that
you need a lot less than,
what are some examples of
some particularly interesting
things that you learned?
For me, the, uh,
the most interesting I
learned was actually how much
diversity there south there.
Um, because I, I mean, first of all,
there's no such thing as a common
Nordic identity. Uh, I don't know if,
I mean there are some Nordic people here
for sure. I mean there might be more,
but I think all, all of us living
in the Nordic region, we, uh,
we feel a strong identity
connected to where we're from,
but that's usually not like, hey, I'm
Nordic. You know, I'm Swedish. Um,
and I think that because of this we
might not have been sort of receptive to,
uh, uh, be sort of our neighboring
cultures as much as we should have.
At least that's sort of applies to me.
And just traveling around, you know,
meeting people in their
homes, uh, talking about food,
seeing what the actually cook and
bake on an everyday basis. Uh,
it's just been eye opening.
How much, you know,
difference in cultural
diversity is out there.
What's the difference in bread between
hand kneading it and he's a kitchen aid.
Uh,
I mean the kitchen aid specifically,
it's a one way of machine needing but,
and you know,
it has a specific expression because of
the size of the bowl and the way moves.
But I think that if we look at like
machine process versus hand processed,
like theoretically there
has to be no difference.
Like it doesn't have to be
any difference. Um, and uh,
because the doe doesn't know what's
going on to it, you know, and,
and there is a lot of different machines
that can take care of this and this is
something that I've spoken to
a lot of bakers about and, uh,
very begrudgingly and most of them agree
that the machine should be able to do
with exactly as well as a human being,
but then they were a hundred parts of the,
uh,
baking process that machines at least
not yet are able to replicate perfectly.
In your research,
did you find any regional difference?
It's when the difference depending on
where they've grown up thinking about all.
Okay.
What about different kinds of brands?
Different coming from different
parts at least at all,
just so mixed into processing.
We don't really know.
The thing is that, I mean,
if you look further back,
there was more regional diversity when,
when farmers would take and produce
their own seed from their crop and then
receive that next year,
you would have a larger degree of
genetic of the diversity and whatever was
produced in various regions,
not just grains, but today,
I mean for the last hundred plus years,
uh,
pretty much all of the commercial growers
of cereal crops used to same handful
of, uh, varieties. Um,
and in this book it's
about this documentary,
a object about what
people bake today at home,
meaning that most of the research has
also been into what people use at home,
which is largely the same types of flour.
Yeah,
I just got, it would be interesting
to have terroir of different,
it will be very interesting to
have terroir of different grains,
but it's actually nonexistent.
Yeah. Uh, I mean there are,
we buy for to fabric and
we buy a specific variety,
so various grains from specific
farms and we used up, but I mean,
that's a very extreme
expression of a baking.
That's not a at all representative
of where people bake in the home.
And I think that's,
we will most likely never have that
type of variety in the home. Yes.
For practical reasons.
I mean,
and then whether that's sad or
whether it's efficient than good,
I mean that's up to
anyone. And for me, uh,
I mean I love being part of making this
book has also be too mean to sort of
remove my opinions from
the content matter,
which is not easy all the time because
when you run a restaurant like five
weekend,
it's all about pushing your agenda and
your opinion and showcasing that in the
food.
But for it to be documentary
and representative for
the region that I had to
sort of remove that therapeutic
therapeutic, there's to make, I mean,
I think that the pretty much all
baking can be fairly therapeutic.
I like making chocolate old new balls,
uh,
which is essentially butter and
sugar and oatmeal and cocoa powder.
And very rarely does it ever make
it to the both stage. I mean,
usually it's sort of just disappears.
Meanwhile,
you mentioned earlier talking
about the fresh sheets.
I've definitely found it very frustrating.
And following Nordic case
because the expectations of like
you mentioned that you did some testing
changes.
Did you find that you have to make
are with, how did you acknowledge,
yeah, so it's actually, it's a
bit complicated because as I said,
it's a documentary books and none of the
recipes have been adapted in any way.
Uh, not, you know,
to sort of better fit specific
territories or even if,
I mean I've seen a lot of recipes are,
I'm like I can do that so much
better if I change it to the bit,
but I haven't done that.
And the same thing goes here.
So what I've done though is that I
written narrative texts and I sort of
provided information on
some of these topics.
Like I written how yeast
functions for example,
and what the differences would
be between freshmen right east.
And then we explain that a little bit in
how to substitute and how to work with
that. I written about the variation in
different flowers because there's a huge
difference in flowers across the world,
not just the thing in American
counterparts, but everywhere.
And even within the u s there's a
big difference in how flower behaves.
And then there is also other recipes
you know what to do if you don't have a
giant wood fired brick oven for example,
when you make bad breads and
stuff like that. Um, but it,
this documentary and the recipes as such,
they are exactly as they
are in the Nordic region.
I'm really curious to hear more
about the interaction of identity and
nationality. Um, do you
do if the case that um,
there's not a sort of,
there hasn't been an this,
this identity of a culture because there's
so much regional diversity and then
also on the other side you're,
your books are branding this idea
of Nordic cuisine or are you,
do you think there a broader Nordic
identity you'd be on the national
identity that is emerging or
that you would like to see?
I think that it's always been there. It's
just that, you know, I was living there.
We don't like to acknowledge it because
we feel more strongly for our specific
national identity rather than like your
common Nordic one and the common and the
Nordic region. I mean it's a geographical
region. It's not a cultural region. Um,
but there are a lot of things that sort
of bind us together a culturally as well.
Um, but they're equally many
things that sort of tell us apart.
And one interesting thing that you can
see when it comes to the, you know,
where people used to cook and still cooks
today and as well for that matter is
that at at this sort of
base you have these uh,
claim math. Again, geographical
differences. That's a
constant, that's just there.
And then on top on top of that you'll
have a geographic or a cultural layer as
well, like a little cultural
filter that informs a, you know,
what people do with these
geographical circumstances.
And most of that I would say it actually
depends on whom occupied whom in the
past. Um, which is sort of strange
and a bit interesting and funny,
but you can divide the Nordic
region into two cultural regions.
One that's Swedish influenced and that's
like from Sweden and then Finland and
around the Baltics or the
Baltic countries in Poland.
And they're not part
of the Nordics anymore,
but they have a very
distinctive sort of Swedish, uh,
influence on that cultural layer,
on top of the geography.
And then the western bit would have
the same with Danish influence.
And it really shows because in
that cultural legion, for example,
you have green than the
Faroe Islands and Iceland,
I mean green than a Faroe islands
are still part of Denmark.
Iceland was occupied by then
more for many, many years.
Uh, none of these islands,
um,
would have ever seen any green before
the deans came because the climates,
you know, it doesn't really
support growing grains. Uh,
and there are so isolated.
But today they have a bread culture and
you can trace almost all of it back to
the Danish cultural influence.
All of these countries,
they will have their own version,
or for example,
like the very iconic and Danish Rye bread,
but made to suit their circumstances
on Iceland, for example,
the country that has
almost no trees, the, uh,
source of energy to heat the home was
traditionally a peat moss that was dug out
of a peat bog and lug it home and dry
it and then burnt and obviously a very
laborious process to create fuel,
meaning that people weren't exactly
inclined to fire up a giant brick oven to
bake a loaf of bread. So, I mean,
before the Danes came there to,
didn't really have any, any
type of baked goods at all, uh,
with the deans came people from
Denmark who obviously lived on Iceland,
uh, because it was occupied,
you know, managing everything
they wanted their bread.
And Iceland has a lot
of volcanic activity.
So what people did instead was just
dig holes in the ground outside of the
villages and lower a bucket of
Rye bread down into the hole,
come back in the day after in the morning
and pick up a loaf of steamed bread.
And that still goes on today and
he's very easy to think, you know,
when you're in Iceland that,
oh,
they've been doing this
for like a thousand years,
but they haven't, you know,
they'd been doing it for like 200 years,
which is not very long and
historic or historical perspective.
That's not so bad.
What is your favorite recipe in this book?
I mean, as I said before, it's been,
most of the process has been about me not
imposing too much of my opinion on the
content matter.
Um,
and the choice of recipes it entirely
independent on what I think is good and
bad.
It's about what represents the most
people in the region and the most parts of
the regions as well as possible.
But then naturally, I mean,
there are recipes that for various reasons
I personally feel more for and they
will probably be things that has to
do with my childhood. Like, yeah,
soft Swedish flatbreads.
For example,
I'm going to chocolate balls
I mentioned earlier. Um,
and then things I didn't know existed,
like the Icelandic Rye bread.
Also to me very appealing if even
if I've never baked it myself.
I mean just the fact
that it's sort of exists.
I have a question about flowers and
you just have a recommendation for a
resource professional or the non
culinary school educated person.
I love baking and Rick started,
we have always been interested
in alternative flours
and I'm really interested
more in wheat flours.
Just the variation of the flowers and
understanding of protein content and how
they all interact and what brands to buy.
Simple things like that.
I find myself playing different
places on the Internet and googling
and I don't know what's right and I'm
just wondering if there's a central
resource that you would tell
someone to go to. Oh, this is it.
The education on flour.
Um, I don't have one specific
one that's available here.
Uh, and what I do know is that there
is like a huge amount of difference,
not just in what grains
that are used to make flour,
but also in the various processes
use like how things are milled, uh,
how things are age,
how they are transported and so on.
And it all affects how
they bake in the end.
So I think that the only thing that I can
suggest just, I mean try buying flour,
that seems to be good, you know, cause
how many a hundred reasons then yes,
the pure functionality,
it might be that it's organic,
that is mill close to where you
live, whatever by that and then, um,
use only that,
I'm thinking you were learning how it
behaves and then you'll be able to adapt
recipes into that, you know? Um,
and it's very hard to be general
about these things because they, they,
they differ so much and there are no,
I mean,
I haven't found any great books on this.
There's lots of research papers. I mean,
you can do it into like university,
the search engines and you can look
for things and read people's crappy
abstracts about, you know, wheat
kernels and things like that. Uh,
and it is very interesting. Um, but
maybe someone should write that though.
Just defined baking as
the transformation and,
uh,
my family is a Norwegian word.
I never, yes. To protect the rights. Well,
never. Yes, potato. Yeah. Yeah.
Is that it does anything about it.
[inaudible] is a,
the traditional Norwegian flatbread and
the big difference between left Sir and
most of the other flat breads in the
Nordic region is that they are griddled,
they're not baked in an oven and uh,
they also use other, it's not
just flower based, I should say.
Quite a few of them have potato in them.
A lot of them have peas in them
as well and things like that.
And the reason why they're not oven
bake this stuff, most of Norway,
uh, it's a bit like Iceland in the
sense that there are not any like large,
deep forests in most of the country.
And that's compared to Sweden for example,
where like the generation,
all my grand grandparents,
I mean they all had a thousand
hectares. So pine forest, you know,
that was pretty much worthless.
All it was good for was fire wood.
So they had a lot of that.
Then therefore we have a tradition of
these great big brick ovens on every farm.
There is one of those solo,
our flatbreads are baked in that Norway,
they didn't have access
to a few in that way,
so they had to be more energy efficient
and a little fire under a grid.
It'll, you know, it's a, it's a much
more efficient way of baking flatbreads.
So I think,
yeah,
and your research, you try to cut off,
like you said, uh, alternate his recipes.
Are there any recipes or like red spade
very far off regions of you worried
about will kind of die out or anything
that you want to do to preserve?
So this is also something that I realized
during this process and before this I
think that I was more on the sort of
opinion that a traditional food culture is
very important to preserve acidosis.
And I've come to realize more
and more that is actually,
that's completely wrong because food
culture has to be allowed to evolve and we
will always, um, eat what makes
sense to us wherever we are,
whoever we are and whatever
time it will be. Um,
what's important though
is to preserve the, uh,
knowledge to make sure that food culture
is properly and accurately documented
because it's a waste of knowledge
if it just sort of, you know,
stops being practiced and then
everyone just forgets about that.
It might've taken a generations
are thousands of years,
was sort of empirical study and living to
come up with a lot of these techniques.
But, uh, and, and this is a, it's
a hard thing actually because, uh,
almost everyone has doesn't, you
know, no, quite agree with me on this.
Almost everyone,
I think often thinking just sort of a
says that's these traditional service.
So important to keep allowing, but like
who's going to keep them alive? I mean,
in Sweden we have sour
herring, for example, the
stinkiest food on planet earth.
Um, and I think that, I mean,
wait 30 more years and
it's going to be gone.
Okay.
And I'm not going to be
sorry that it's gone,
but I will be very sorry if the knowledge
on how to make it will disappear. Yes.
Because we don't eat it anymore.
No.
Hello.
It seems to me like
a lot of us eat home cooked food everyday.
I haven't seen that to the same
standards and other pieces though.
First of all.
That's true.
I think, yeah, I think it's
absolutely true. Uh, even today,
I mean the, the, the development
in the Nordic region,
especially in the bigger cities
are people eat more and more out.
It becomes more and more like
other parts of the world. Um,
but we still eat a bigger part of our
meals in the home cooked by ourselves than
almost any other western culture does.
And I think it has to do with the
historically a lot of different reasons.
One of them being scared of the population
that is just not enough people in a
large part of the region
to sustain restaurants.
And then I think that there are cultural
factors on top of that as well as
religion, for example,
and many other things. Um,
yeah.
But what I do know though is that this
is one of the reasons why Nordic food
culture and making culture is so little
understood because it's inaccessible,
not just the way I spoke about before.
With like stop a recorded information
but also like the practical act of eating
Nordic food.
I mean if you go to Sweden for example,
as a tourist and you go to stock
and when you think to yourself,
I'm going to have, you know, one
traditional Swedish mean when I'm here,
you're not going to get that is not
a single restaurant in Stockholm that
producers and uh,
uh,
something that's remotely close to like
an authentic version or people eat in
their homes.
Okay.
Cause that's not what restaurants
are about in that region.
And that differs a lot from um,
central and southern Europe for example.
I mean,
it's very easy to go to Spain and go to
a restaurant and find something that's
definitely a bit adapted to
the world of restaurants.
But that fairly accurately represents
the same thing as you would
cook at home. Yeah. The question also,
is there any tradition of high altitude,
uh, we don't have that much high
altitude in the Nordic region and,
and where are we have a bit of altitude.
Uh, I mean, in Sweden, I mean the, like,
the tallest mountains are like 1500
or so meters and no one lives there.
I mean, traditionally has no one lived up
there. It's like we're, we're, I'm from,
uh, which is considered quite
high in altitude, is 350 meters.
So, uh, so I don't have a specific,
uh, any specific knowledge of it.
I know that we had some feedback from
like recipe test or something in Mexico
City, for example. Uh, that a lot of
the recipes behave very differently.
Thank you guys for coming in
today and thanks for [inaudible].
[inaudible].